well one of the issues we're talking
about there was this decision to
extend the gap between vaccine doses up
to 12 weeks now it does
worry several groups including the
doctors association and we can talk to
uh that one of their members and gp
rosie shire good to see you this morning
look
the health secretary there saying you
know they'd rather give people sort of
50
protection and get more people out there
protected rather than get
everyone doubled up with their doses why
is a plan does
not that not work for you good morning
steven um
on behalf of the doctors association uk
thank you for having me on the program
um we're really concerned by this
decision to
extend the vaccination schedule for the
pfizer vaccination
from what was studied uh when they
designed the vaccination
which was that people would have two
doses of the fisa vaccination
three weeks apart and that showed that
it gave them
90 percent immunity to then
extend this to give them two doses 12
weeks apart
and what really concerns us is we don't
know what happens if you don't give
that second dose of vaccination after
three weeks
and yet the i mean you're quite right
and
in a sense no one is claiming at this
stage that they do know but the health
secretary
and some others including some of the
scientific advisors saying well
even with that uncertainty to get people
some level of immunity is more important
it would be great if we could say yes
they're going to have some level of
immunity
that will continue after that three week
days but think about the worst case
scenario that after three weeks
that immunity just wanes completely or
maybe
if we then give the booster at 12 weeks
that's just not good enough
the fact is that people are being
vaccinated now and they're being put
into
what is effectively an unregulated
unlicensed
trial whereby they're receiving this
vaccination
on the understanding that then they
don't know what's going on
and on the ground that's really hard for
us as
gps as vaccinators to have to explain
that to people so that they fully
understand the implications of what's
going on
and if we give them the oxford
vaccination we can say to them
you will get your second dose in 12
weeks time and that's what the study
did and they show that you get this
level of immunity after that
with the fisa vaccination when we give
that we're having to say to people
you're going to get some immunity and we
know
we don't know what's going to happen
after that three week period
because it hasn't been looked at and
you're going to have to then
wait till 12 weeks and we hope it's
going to be 12 weeks because the rules
were suddenly changed
when in december when we first started
vaccinating we told these people you
were getting your second dose in three
weeks
and suddenly we had to cancel all these
second doses
so we just need more information to be
able to tell people
so that they understand the risk that
we're having to to go through at the
moment
but the chief medical officer chris
whittie has said you know this is a
it's a public health decision and he
thinks it's a reasonable thing to do
because in his words our major
limitation
of the number of vaccines we actually
have to give it's not the ability to
vaccinate it's a number of vaccines
that have to be given so in terms of
public health
he thinks it's worth the risk they've
obviously looked into this and that's
really
it's reassuring to know i think that
they have looked at it but we don't know
all the data around this we don't know
what's been considered
and we're the ones on the ground who are
actually talking to people about the
vaccination
and we're the ones that are having to
take the consent and when we talk about
consent we always talk about informed
consent so people understand
the risks and the benefits to a
procedure or a vaccination
and i also think it's really important
just to mention here that we're hearing
a lot of statistics about
three quarters of over 80s have been
vaccinated well actually no they haven't
been
three quarters of over 80 year olds have
received their first
dose of the vaccination and they're not
going to be fully vaccinated
until they've received that second dose
and if they've had the fisa vaccination
we don't know if they are going to be
fully vaccinated when they receive the
second dose
because that schedule has been changed
from what was studied
and what was licensed is there a
logistical issue from a sort of gp
perspective in keeping track of people
over you know a minimum of a three-month
period to get them back in for a second
dose
so at the moment everything is recorded
onto a system called pinnacle and then
that gets
uploaded onto the patient's records it
is a potential logistical problem of
having to phone people again
when we initially gave the fisa in
december we could say to people
this is your fisa vaccination please
come back in three weeks time
same time same place and you'll get your
second vaccination
and that was great that was really easy
for people to understand and it didn't
take
the the manpower the people on the
phones phoning people up
now with this three-month gap we're
going to have to get everybody back on
the phone
phoning all those five million people to
say please can you come back
to have your second vaccination at this
time this place
um another issue we're having is knowing
what vaccinations we're getting and when
we're getting them
and we're not seeing much transparency
about the delivery schedule and the
supply chains
um so we can only book people in a week
in advance
if we knew more what we were going to
get and we could have guarantees of how
many vaccinations we were going to get
and also which type of vaccination we
were going to get we would be able to
plan much more efficiently
and hopefully increase the vaccinating
dr good to talk to you this morning
thank you well